this video is brought to you by movie go
to movie.com
thomasflight for your extended 30 day
free trial point for me
interested in and knowledgeable about my
girlfriend's work
for jake
how's the paper it's nowhere actually
i really do need to get back tonight
deal with it first thing i'll get you
home
chains as you watch i'm thinking of
ending things
you might start to think that the world
the film inhabits feels
a bit off of course if you've seen any
of writer and director charlie kaufman's
films before you are probably
expecting this but even before anything
really strange happens while it's just
two characters riding in a car
having a fairly normal conversation
things feel weird in a film any sense we
have of its mood and its environment is
produced
by the filmmaking one of the most
powerful of those techniques
working almost invisibly to help create
i'm thinking of ending things
strange unsettling atmosphere is the
editing
in much of the first half of the car
ride the tension and awkwardness is
driven
by the performances the editing
deliberately
flowing with the rhythm of the
conversation she hasn't been
well what's going on with her just
saying if you want to stop for a
snack or anything like that it
would probably be fine um
in terms of appetite spoiling and it
might even be
advisable i'm fine okay
editing in a conversation like this
often mimics the flow of attention
in a real life conversation if you
imagine yourself sitting between the
characters
looking back and forth there's a slight
lag between when someone speaks and when
your attention can shift to them
what's going on with her just saying if
you want to stop for a
snacker if someone interrupts the
speaker it will take a small beat for
you to shift your attention to the other
speaker
child being father is a man and all you
a fan of wordsworth then
and then when a speaker seems to have
reached their conclusion you might
expectantly
shift your attention to the other person
waiting for a response
they do it every few years for obvious
reasons and who does it every few years
editors mimic this type of flow of
attention in a conversation
to help their cut feel natural and
invisible of course editors aren't bound
by these rules
sometimes editors will defy the natural
rhythm of a conversation
in order to place specific emphasis on a
character's perspective
or reaction and sometimes they might
adopt a different pace to maintain the
overall
aesthetic or pacing of the film if it
calls for longer or shorter takes
but you could also defy this natural
rhythm editing
instead in a slightly off-kilter rhythm
using cuts that are asynchronous to the
conversation
to create an uncomfortable unsettling
feeling or to illustrate the disconnect
between two characters in a conversation
a great example of this in the film is
the moment in the car ride right after
they pass
the swing set that's uh did you see that
swing set we just passed
what's makes sense it was weird it was
this beautiful new swing set in front of
an abandoned
it house i didn't see it why would that
be there
i mean clearly no one has lived in that
house for years
moving in and they brought the swing set
first that's all i can think of
all right that's that seems like an
unlikely sequence of events
here the editing in a sense loses its
rhythm
cuts happen just a little bit too early
or too late instead of following the
natural rhythm of attention i just
talked about it's
in effect almost as if the editor
momentarily loses focus
here it cuts to jake way too early did
you see that swing set we just passed
what swing sounds weird and again here
it cuts too late to
catch his line a new swing set in front
of an abandoned house
here we linger on jake past where it
feels like we should cut back to the
young woman
that seems like an unlikely sequence of
events
but when we do finally cut back to her
her line is over
an unlikely sequence of events any of
these little things by themselves
would probably not be noticeable but
when they're all used together
in such close proximity you can feel the
effect
as you watch it the trick here is that
the off-kilter nature of the edit
is dramatic enough that you notice the
effect
but not so bad that it registers as bad
editing for the audience you want the
audience to notice the
effect not the cause of the effect it's
similar to the balance that has to be
struck in the film's cinematography here
you want
the composition to feel cramped you want
to
push things beyond what would normally
be
a comfortable composition but you still
don't want to create
bad cinematography you want the audience
to
feel cramped and be thinking about the
story not
thinking about the cinematography as bad
later in the film editing is used in a
more obvious way
in the barn characters seem to jump and
move in time without any
deliberate transition shots there you
have it
the sheep what what happened to the
lambs what
i don't know what you're asking me
they're already dead so
what else obviously jumps in time happen
all the time
in between scenes and films or even in
scenes with montages
but to have deliberate skips in time
without
any noticeable transition shots or
shots that give the effect of time
passing makes the scene feel off-kilter
come on i'll show you the the old pen
where we used to keep the pigs
they had to put them down it's too bad
situation
again while it's more noticeable here
that difference between what constitutes
comfortable and
uncomfortable is subtle look at how
different the jump in time feels if we
add just a short transitionary shot
there you have it the sheep
what what happened to the lambs what i
don't know what you're asking
me they're already dead so just adding
those two seconds of footage gives us a
sense of time passing and so when we cut
back to the characters and they've moved
it doesn't feel
abrupt or abrasive again this is what
you would normally want to do to make
your editing feel invisible
and make the audience comfortable but
kaufman and his editor are subverting
the correct way to edit to deliberately
create
an uncomfortable effect shifts in time
like this are used periodically
throughout the rest of the film
in this scene the characters seem to
shift from interacting with a dog that
doesn't seem to be in the room to
looking at a photo of the dog you're a
stinky wet
monster huh sorry
sorry about his smell
jake he's a dog it's fine
here the shot of the photo could work as
a transition shot but
it's cut far too short for the
transition to really feel natural
watch how different it feels if you just
extend the length of the shot of the
photo
a little bit his smell jake he's a dog
it's fine jimmy
these incongruities in editing along
with the many other ways the film breaks
rules of continuity and costume or
character details shifts in time in the
story or even randomly cutting lines of
dialogue out of the sound mix
all work together to create the film's
overall uneasy
and unsettling atmosphere one of the
things that makes editing such a
difficult craft to master
is that the difference between
uncomfortable and perfect timing can be
very subtle and there's no formula you
can memorize that will tell you exactly
when to time a cut or
how long a transition shot should be to
feel natural
and even if there was a formula that
formula wouldn't tell you
when to break the rules like kaufman and
his editor are doing here
creating these kinds of effects involves
having an intuition for that rhythm
and then knowing how to subvert that
intuition without drawing
attention to the subversion and these
things are difficult to teach
i can make videos breaking down what
other people have done but the only way
to really develop that sense is by
watching
a ton of well-edited material and
through practice
by editing material yourself
thank you to mubi for sponsoring this
video movie is an online streaming
platform with a heavy focus
on curation you can go to movie.com
thomasflight for your extended 30-day
free trial where
you'll be able to watch anything in
mubi's library recently i found on movie
this documentary called obit
it's about new york times obituary
writers and i know this movie is
probably not everyone's type of thing
but
i love it and it's the kind of thing i
never would have found
if it weren't for movie you could watch
obit right now on their library and if
that's not your thing they add a new
film to the collection
every day they had art house films
independent films
classic films and new festival favorites
you can check it all out right now at
movie.com
thomasflight sign up to get your
extended 30 day free trial and check out
the films they have
available
thank you for watching this video
special thank you to my patrons right
now for my five dollar patrons i'm doing
a thing where
i let them pick a movie for me to watch
and then i make a video reviewing that
movie so if you want to get in on that
or you want to learn about the other
rewards that are available to people who
support my channel
you can go to patreon.com thomasflight i
suppose i watched
too many movies